the gravity of the president's language
was sinking in even before he was off
the ground in New York by the time he'd
arrived back in Washington with his
press secretary at his side he'd have
been fully aware of the impact the off
the cuff off camera remarks were having
he told an audience that a Democratic
fundraiser we have not faced the
prospect of Armageddon since Kennedy and
the Cuban Missile Crisis he Putin is not
joking when he talks about potential use
of tactical nuclear weapons or
biological or chemical weapons because
his military is you might say
significantly underperforming and then
the president said this I don't think
there's any such thing as the ability to
easily use a tactical nuclear weapon and
not end up with Armageddon
that last sentence seems to be
particularly Stark in essence what he's
saying is that if Putin uses a nuclear
weapon in Ukraine the likely conclusion
is Armageddon now that might well be a
threat a warning to Putin know where
this leads know what might happen the
danger of course is that it's a warning
which ends up playing out
the Russian leader celebrated his
birthday in Moscow with a small
collection of loyalist leaders
but it was his comments a week ago which
still ring loud
[Music]
he said the United States is the only
country in the world to have used
nuclear weapons twice destroying the
Japanese cities of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki he added
they set a precedent
this is this is serious both sides are
fairly dug in on what the consequences
will be in the event of escalation what
we don't know yet is what either side
will be willing to accept short of
complete annihilation of the other side
and that's the nub of it who blinks
first back in 1962 at a minute to
midnight Armageddon Kennedy and Kristoff
found a way out the Soviet missiles were
removed from Cuba the American ones left
turkey the Cuban Missile Crisis was over
White House officials insist the
president's remarks are not based on new
information consistent messaging they
say or loose language either way the
backdrop Now isn't a 1960s Cold War but
a real one in Europe where calculations
are Hasty and miscalculations very
possible Mark Stone Sky News in
Washington